Stunt performers are the unsung heroes
of Hollywood productions — and Ahsoka's
are some of the finest in the biz. So
who are the faces behind the fights?
Standing in as the stunt double
for a lead protagonist is no easy
job — especially when that protagonist is
also a former Jedi. Rosario Dawson handles
the majority of Ahsoka's scenes in the
series, including a lot of the action,
but she doesn't do it all. That's
where Michelle C. Lee comes in.
Though Lee is an immensely skilled martial
artist and stuntwoman, she's also a talented
actor in her own right. You may know her from
her role as Oksana in 2021's Black Widow,
or as Violet on the Paramount+ adventure
series Blood & Treasure. Lee's stunt credits
are extensive, including everything from Top
Gun: Maverick to Suicide Squad to Pacific Rim.
Beyond film and television, Lee has
also contributed her skills as a motion
capture artist to a number of major video
games. Those credits include Uncharted:
The Lost Legacy, The Last of Us:
Left Behind, and most notably,
the Mortal Kombat series. Lee has worked
extensively in the latter franchise,
even playing Mileena in the 2013 web series Mortal
Kombat: Legacy. Perhaps it's no surprise, then,
that she was chosen to take on such an important
and intensive role during production on Ahsoka.
Sabine Wren has a unique fighting style,
to say the least. She has trained under
Jedi such as Kanan Jarrus and Ahsoka Tano,
as well as Mandalorians and even instructors
at the Imperial Academy. As a result, her
approach in combat is something of a mishmash,
equal parts rebel bounty hunter,
Mandalorian warrior, and Jedi Knight.
"Take us out… Padawan."
While Natasha Liu Bordizzo does a lot of the work
in bringing that unique fighting style to life,
she has some help, too. Ahsoka Episode 7 credits
Chau Naumova as her stunt double — a younger
performer who still seems to be making a
name for herself in Hollywood. Though she
isn't marked as a stunt performer for the show
on IMDb, Naumova's page does also credits her
as playing the role of Lieutenant Jensu,
one of the X-wing pilots who accompanies
General Hera Syndulla to Seatos. That particular
squadron is apparently full of stunt performers,
as longtime Din Djarin stand-in Brendan
Wayne also flies a fighter in the same scene.
Apart from Ahsoka, Naumova's only credit
on IMDb is for playing the Street Fighter
character Ibuki in a low-budget
TV series. According to iStunt,
Naumova was also a competitor on Season
4 of NBC's World of Dance. Hopefully,
her multiple roles in Ahsoka will help to elevate
her profile and career in the years to come.
For a villain with the poise and presence of Ray
Stevenson's Baylan Skoll, you need a stunt double
equal to the task. And that's exactly what the
Ahsoka crew found when they hired Morgan Benoit.
You may not know Benoit's name,
but you've almost surely seen his
work. He was a stunt double for
Keanu Reeves in 2013's 47 Ronin,
and he has stunt credits on major action films
like Terminator: Dark Fate, Renfield, and Dune.
All of those credits should have been
enough to get Benoit the role of Stevenson's
stunt double on Ahsoka, but it probably
didn't hurt that he also had experience
in the Star Wars universe. He has performed
stunt work on The Mandalorian since 2020,
and he even lent his talents to the
big-budget video game Star Wars Jedi:
Survivor earlier in 2023. In short, he was
the perfect man for the job — and Baylan
Skoll's intense, aggressive lightsaber
fights stand as testament to that fact.
Having worked on The Mandalorian probably
wasn't a requirement for stunt performers
to get hired on Ahsoka, but it clearly wasn't
a mark against them. Morgan Benoit wasn't the
only performer to move from one Star Wars
show to the other; Alicia Vela-Bailey,
the stunt double for Ivanna Sakhno's
character Shin Hati, did as well.
In addition to her previous Star
Wars work, Vela-Bailey has earned
credits as Gal Gadot's stunt double
for Wonder Woman and Batman v Superman:
Dawn of Justice. She also played a Themysciran
warrior early on in the first Wonder Woman movie.
Star Wars isn't the only Disney franchise that
Vela-Bailey has experience in, either. She's a
true veteran of the Marvel universe, appearing
in several of the Netflix shows, including The
Punisher and The Defenders, as well as Guardians
of the Galaxy Vol. 3 and Agents of S.H.I.E.L.D.,
in which she also played the role of Alisha
Whitley. Vela-Bailey has lent her talents to the
Avatar franchise as well, playing a member of the
villainous Recom unit in Avatar: The Way of Water;
on that production, she also worked as a stunt
double for both Sigourney Weaver and Zoe Saldana.
Fans of Star Wars Rebels were more than elated at
the end of Ahsoka Episode 6, when Eman Esfandi's
Ezra Bridger finally made his on screen debut. The
character is instantly recognizable as the beloved
Jedi rogue from the animated series, and Esfandi
captures Ezra's spirit and personality perfectly.
"The Force is my ally. It's all I need."
It was even more exciting for fans to see Ezra
leap into action in Ahsoka's seventh episode,
on which Esfandi was assisted
by his stunt double, Jason Chu.
Once again, we've got a Mandalorian alumnus here.
Chu has also worked on Disney projects such as
Agents of S.H.I.E.L.D. and Captain America:
Civil War, as well as multiple entries in the
modern Planet of the Apes franchise. He's been
particularly busy over the past several years,
lending his skills to movies such as
Army of the Dead, Blade Runner 2049,
and Free Guy, among other projects. One
thing's for sure: He's not inexperienced.
Ezra's Force-centric fighting style in Ahsoka is
a lot of fun to watch, and, if their social media
activity is any indication, Chu and Esfandi forged
a strong bond during production. The actor was
commenting on his stunt double's Instagram posts
as recently as December 2022, pumping him up over
some snazzy pics. But you'd expect nothing less
from the Ezra we all know and love, wouldn't you?